[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a diario de copas un espacio
de france 24 en el que actualizamos toda
la información referente a la copa
américa y la eurocopa y estos son los
titulares brasil venció venezuela y
colombia a ecuador en el comienzo de la
copa américa que puso a rodar el balón
en medio de incertidumbre y críticas por
la situación sanitaria en brasil son
estos conjuntos posibles finalistas en
breve el análisis
a pocas horas del debut de argentina en
el torneo
lionel mesi muestra preocupación por el
riesgo de disputar la copa en medio de
la pandemia argentina jugará esta tarde
frente a su similar de chile rememorando
las finales del torneo en 2015 y 2016
triunfo de países bajos el conjunto de
fráncfort superó a ucrania 3 por 2 con
un gol sobre los minutos finales está la
'naranja mecánica' para pelear por el
título del torneo
y se cumplió el primer día de copa
américa luego de un periodo de
incertidumbre es que hasta requerido de
una decisión judicial para poder llevar
adelante el torneo al igual que en
nuestras anteriores emisiones contamos
con la presencia de sara castro
directora del diario 'as' colombia quien
nos va a acompañar en cada jornada hasta
el final de ambas competencias
bienvenidas ahora hola luis un gusto
estar con ustedes unas jornadas muy
interesantes de fútbol así que
arranquemos por supuesto que sí y hay
que hablar entonces de la copa américa
porque brasil pentacampeón del mundo y
nueve veces campeón de copa américa la
última de ellas en 2019 comenzó el
torneo venciendo a venezuela 3 goles por
0 fue el resultado del partido los
tantos del compromiso fueron anotados
por marquinhos a los 23 minutos neymar
júnior de penal a los 64 y gabriel
barbosa a los 89 la canarinha sara
supera a un rival que quizás no está en
los papeles viene afrontando múltiples
problemas pero es la selección de
venezuela
para medir en qué condiciones está
brasil en estos momentos es un contexto
muy difícil porque veníamos de anunciar
que es un equipo con 15 bajas por kobe y
19 así que lo que hizo venezuela ayer
fue muy loable en términos de dignidad
de como colectivamente intentó plantarse
le ha una que es la una de las grandes
favoritas de este torneo por supuesto y
hay que decir que para muchos el partido
ayer fue un poco burocrático 22 minutos
tardó brasil en abrir el marcador frente
a un equipo bastante diezmado pero creo
que lo que sigue demostrando tite que
además llegó a 55 partidos con la
selección de brasil 41 victorias 10
derrotas 10 empates y apenas 4 derrotas
es que es un equipo muy consolidado
entonces si bien no se pueden medir si
está para ser campeón por supuesto es un
muy buen primer paso y creo que el
contexto en el que se vive está como
américa también condicionó a brasil para
demostrar un poco más de fútbol
mencionaste en el caso de venezuela ya
se venía adelantando la situación del
conjunto venezolano por los temas de
kobe 19 dentro del seleccionado pre
escuchemos qué fue lo que dijo jose
peseiro al concluir este compromiso
brutal 30 brutal 30 mira brasil ha
ganado por 12 13 equipos o 14 goles a
otros equipos que tenían otros jugadores
no es brutal entonces hasta ahora
nuestro mejor equipo perdió 2-0
obviamente él kobe tuvo una influencia
en otro duelo de la jornada colombia
superó un gol por cero a la selección de
ecuador el tanto del conjunto
neogranadino fue obra de edwin cardona a
los 42 minutos de la primera parte sobre
ello escuchemos qué fue lo que dijo
reinaldo rueda tras el compromiso
un partido muy intenso e indudablemente
que
la selección colombia es un juego muy
inteligente de gran aplicación sabíamos
de las capacidades del rival y de su
potencia y su explosividad en todos los
duelos
y bueno creo que como lo dije el día de
ayer es importante aprovechar estos 20
días en la medida que hagamos un buen
camino de conocernos mejor con el grupo
de jugadores y que esto nos brinde muy
buenas alternativas para por el camino
largo de todo lo que tanto es la copa
américa como la clasificatoria
y aprovechar estos días para
concentrarse conocerse y mejorar en el
futuro palabras de reinaldo rueda pero
con lo que hemos visto se hará de
reinaldo rueda al frente de la selección
colombia en estos últimos partidos
crees que colombia está para pelear el
título de la copa américa hay dos frases
que vamos a escuchar mucho la esta copa
américa y es que todos van a promover
cambios y a probar alternativas creo que
estos primeros partidos van a ser de eso
porque porque de cinco equipos en el
grupo sólo clasifican cuatro esto
significa que las posibilidades son muy
altas y lo de reinaldo rueda en colombia
es interesante son apenas tres partidos
lo que ha mostrado el equipo es una gran
solidaridad y sobre todo compromiso
defensivo si bien ya comentábamos ahora
esas dos escenas en el partido frente
argentinas en donde las
desconcentraciones marcaron pero en
general el equipo se ha mostrado sólido
defensivamente incluso ayer ante un
ecuador que fue bastante intenso en
ataque y que los puso en problemas sobre
todo en el primer tiempo creo que eso es
lo principal ahora el equipo de ayer
contaba con siete cambios respecto a lo
que vimos en él
en barranquilla frente argentina lo cual
indica esa necesidad también del técnico
de conocer con qué fichas juega no sólo
para la copa américa que una vez se
clasifica cuarto seguramente va a poder
pelear la sino también pensando en las
eliminatorias al mundial por supuesto
que así será pero en brasil y en gran
parte de américa latina existe
preocupación por los contagios que kobe
19 de ellos no escapan algunos jugadores
y lionel messi quien pertenece a la
selección de argentina no ocultó su
temor por disputar la copa américa
américa en medio de este brote pero
escuchemos qué fue lo que dijo nos
preocupa la verdad que nos preocupa
porque es un ritmo para todo él
él puede poder contagiar nos podrá
agarrar
rico vi
[Música]
la verdad que nos preocupa intentamos de
descuidar lo de seguir haciendo todo lo
que nos dicen pero bueno no es fácil
porque después pasan estas cosas
nosotros nos enfrentamos contra las
demás selecciones donde también hay
riesgo de contagio y mi mayor sueño de
poder conseguir un título con la
selección estuve muy muy cerquita muchas
veces y lamentablemente no no no se me
dio y intentaré de seguir buscándolo
ataque hasta que pueda ataque ese de
argentina debutará hoy frente al
combinado de chile más adelante paraguay
hará lo propio frente a su similar de
bolivia escuchábamos a lionel messi
quiere ganar algo una vez con la
selección argentina en medio de todo
este contexto está la selección
argentina para pelear ese título en la
copa américa
lo primero es esa voluntad de messi no
que ya como líder del equipo entiende
que a pesar de las circunstancias y
explicando que el contexto es difícil
quiere ganar algo con esta selección son
tres finales perdidas para una
generación de grandes futbolistas
argentinos y es que si revisamos en la
historia desde 1993 argentina no gana
nada a nivel de mayores entonces esta es
una preocupación grande yo creo que el
proceso de scaloni ha dado sus frutos ya
hay posiciones en las que en ese
recambio ha encontrado soluciones creo
que me decía en el partido contra
colombia se encontró un poco más
conforme con lo que tiene que ver con el
funcionamiento colectivo y creo que
también chile es una gran medida los
acabamos de ver enfrentarse en las
eliminatorias un empate 1 a 1 pero en
esta ocasión no estará alexis sánchez
que puso en problemas a esa primera
línea de volantes de la selección
argentina creo que es un buen comienzo
para escalón y que ya necesita empezar a
sumar resultados también hay mucha
presión sobre ellos sobre lo que
significa la albiceleste en el
continente pero creo que messi está muy
muy decidido y sobre todo muy líder creo
que su participación en este torneo va a
ser muy importante pareciera hacer ese
cambio que necesitaba el conjunto
argentino pero pasemos a la eurocopa que
ya cumple cuatro días de competencia en
la jornada de ayer inglaterra
venció a croacia austria hizo lo propio
frente a macedonia del norte y países
bajos a ucrania 3 goles por 2
el triunfo de países bajos sobre los
minutos finales
sara que podemos esperar de esta naranja
mecánica' en el futuro fue uno de los
partidos más emocionantes que se han
vivido en la eurocopa empezó ganando 20
países bajos
luego empata ucrania que también va a
presentar un equipo muy interesante
dirigido por chefs tengo un equipo que
puso en problemas a la defensa de países
bajos sobre todo en las transiciones
rápidas pero hay que quedarse con tres
nombres frank y de jong que es un
fenómeno en ese mediocampo memphis depay
y don frizz que como carrilero creo que
estos nombres para que la gente los
empiece a escuchar seguramente van a dar
mucho de qué hablar en esta eurocopa
vimos unos países bajos que sin duda por
toda la cultura que representa holanda
porque además desde el 2006 no
participaban en un torneo de este tipo
empieza desde el 2016 empieza a sentir
también esa presión y una cultura
futbolística que siempre va a estar en
esa discusión si el técnico frank de
boer está
lo suficiente en el campo de juego yo
creo que se viene hoy también en españa'
que esperamos ver cómo empieza a ser
resurgimiento para escuchar también
mucho la palabra recambio no como estos
equipos que tuvieron generaciones muy
brillantes empiezan a incluir nuevos
jugadores y creo que eso es lo que va a
mostrar hoy el equipo de luis enrique
también en este deuda ante suecia una
jornada que ya empezó hoy muy temprano
con república checa- venciendo a escocia
con marcador de 2 goles por 0 y a esta
hora disputan su partido las
representaciones de polonia y eslovaquia
vamos a ver qué sucede con este españa
entonces frente a suecia más adelante
por lo pronto rápidamente algunas notas
de la eurocopa en este caso es sobre el
jugador christian eriksen que está en
proceso de recuperación de esta manera
le ponemos punto final a este diario de
copas por el día de hoy muchísimas
gracias por su atención sigan con más de
france 24
[Música]